even Catherine well thank you bread a
source familiar with the draft described
it as detailed extensive and thorough in
the ballpark of several hundred pages
the timeline for its release is fluid
but firming up with tentative dates on
the calendar for public congressional
testimony from Inspector General Michael
Horowitz the week of June 4th or June
11th while the inspector general's
office is not commenting on the findings
the source said there is evidence of
potential criminal behavior
the Fox News has not confirmed reports
of at least one referral when deputy FBI
director Andrew McCabe was fired for
lying to federal investigators he told
the inspector general that he disagreed
with the findings arguing that his boss
FBI director James Comey knew about his
engagement with the Wall Street Journal
McCabe claimed Comey wanted to distance
himself from media disclosures because
McKay believed Comey was being
investigated as a leaker Comey was
pressed on the allegation in his Fox
interview did the Inspector General
interview you about your handling of the
memos sure yeah yes has has already and
I expect a report from them not on the
handling of classified information
because that's frivolous but on did I
comply with policy did I comply with my
employment agreement the IGS report
began 16 months ago with bipartisan
support Brett Kevin what's the latest
with the house efforts to obtain these
documents from the DOJ and FBI
well Fox News is told that the
Republican Committee Chairman and their
teams are done meeting with the Justice
Department about records and with a
subpoena in effect the onus they believe
is on the DOJ and FBI to make the
records available a senior Justice
Department officials said they had
offered the Intelligence Committee
chairman Devin newness and the Oversight
Committee chairman trey Gowdy a meeting
today with Deputy Attorney General rod
Rosenstein FBI director Christopher Rea
senior intelligence officials but
lawmakers did not respond I think that
invitation was just to come and talk
again we have asked for documents 46,000
documents that Justice has told us we're
entitled to get we've received 9,000
over the last six months at that pace
we'll be into the second term of
President Trump House Speaker continues
to back the committee's requests for
records Brett